. Let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 40
750.
Let's start today with our caller from the
9 7 8 area code who's calling today from 9
7 8.
Hi, Tom.
I'm just outside the Boston area.
Hey, Tom, what's up?
Hey, how would you say fairly shallow.
Thank you.
I was just wondering your opinion of Marty's
governor or rather the mayor of Boston in
terms of what he's been doing with the virus.
You end with it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, here's the thing.
I've been going basically by Charlie Baker,
the governor's guidelines.
And so I'm embarrassed to say I don't know
whether whether mayor the mayor has put in
place stricter guidelines or not like we can.
Are you up to speed on what he's done?
I'm not really drawing.
I mean, it seems like a grand bargain and
not a lot going on.
No, no, I do not.
I did go for a walk the other day and in a
sort of more tourists, the area there was
like a family of tourists who were taking
pictures and stuff.
And it's like the streets were empty and everything
was closed.
But it was funny because they were sort of
acting like everything was normal.
And I was wondering, you know, that that's
just kind of interesting to be doing that
at this point in time.
They weren't doing anything wrong.
They were walking outside like everybody and
keeping their distance, but they were doing
all the touristy stuff near the common.
It was kind of weird to see.
Yeah.
No, I'm just going hiking along.
I mean, there's not really much else.
There really isn't a restaurant.
And I think that's fine.
You know, I've been on some of the bike paths
in different spots and people.
You do sometimes get people that are pretty
close to each other when they pass.
But the doctor I interviewed earlier during
the week said the odds of transmission when
you're doing that are so, so, so low.
Even if one of the people was sick, which
of course, really, you know, there's there's
asymptomatic people.
But people should if you're feeling anything,
you should be staying at home anyway.
Right.
Yeah.
Yes.
No, I completely agree.
Well, let's all thanks again.
I keep doing the good work.
All right, Tom, Tom from outside Boston, great
to hear from you